hey guys it's joanna here for those of
you who are back in the gym
here is a total body strength and
conditioning workout
this workout will help you to build lean
muscles and
to burn fat so there will be a total of
four
supersets targeting every major muscle
in the body we will be doing two
exercises
back to back without any rest in between
and we want to aim for
four sets okay you want to make sure
that you're lifting
heavy enough to only perform 12 to 15
reps
per set if you can do more reps then
you have to lift heavier let's start
the first episode will be targeting your
legs thighs
glutes as well as your shoulders goblet
squat
and sumo squat single arm press so have
two dumbbells ready one heavy and one
lighter let's start with goblet squat
stance shoulder width apart with your
toes pointed forward
and lift the heavy dumbbell directly in
front of you
push your butt back and squat as low as
you can if you can
try to get your elbows to tap your
thighs and push back
up with your heels push your butt back
engage your core
and keep your body upright
[Music]
once you've completed 12 to 15
repetitions
let's move on to the next workout
[Music]
step wide with your toes pointed out in
a sumo squat position
so we want to be working on your inner
thighs as well as your shoulders
grab the light dumbbell and as you come
up
press the dumbbell above your head lower
yourself back down
and up again so this workout will work
on your glutes
your inner thighs as well as your
shoulders
once you've completed the right arm
switch
and let's continue working on the left
arm
again remember to keep your body upright
so do not
hunch push your butt back and engage
your core throughout
the workout use the strength from your
legs to help you drive
the dumbbell up and you should feel the
work on your shoulders as well
[Music]
well done that is the end of one set
take a short break
and repeat another three more sets
before moving on to the second superset
the second superset will be targeting
your back muscles
traps as well as your shoulders bent
over barbell row
and barbell upright row so for this
super set you will need
two barbells one heavy weight between
15 to 30 kilos and one light weight
between 10 to 15 kilos let's start with
the first workout bend over barbell roll
you will need the heavy barbell for this
workout
so hold the barbell in a reverse grip
position
with your palms facing up push your butt
back
and bend slightly at your hips keeping
your back flat
and chest lifted pull the bar towards
your core
and point your elbows back so do not
spread your elbows out
feel the contraction on your back
muscles before releasing the barbell to
the starting position
and remember to keep your knees soft so
do not lock your knees
this is one of my favorite workouts to
build strength and size
for your back once you've completed all
your wraps
let's immediately move into barbell
upright roll
this workout is really great to target
your shoulders as well as your upper
back
hold the barbell at shoulder width apart
with your palms facing your body
stand upright and pull the barbell up
with your elbows pointed out
just below your chest level lift the
barbell straight up towards
your chest with the elbows pointed out
and
keeping the barbell close to your body
remember to stand tall
brace your core and keep your back
straight with your chest up throughout
the workout
and remember that your arms should not
go higher than your shoulders
so it should just be at about chest
level pause at the top and slowly lower
the barbell down
and again pull it up pause and
lower the barbell down brace your core
keep your body
upright chest lifted throughout the
workout and avoid using momentum to lift
the barbell
up so we want to do at least 12 to 15
repetitions
and that's one set complete another two
to three more sets
before moving on to the third superset
the next superset will be working on
your chest as well as your triceps
alternating dumbbell press and narrow
push-ups
you'll need a bench and one pair of
medium weight dumbbells between 5 to 8
kilos each
so let's start with alternating dumbbell
press lie face up on a flat bench with
your feet
firmly planted on the floor spread your
elbows out and lower the dumbbells to a
90 degree angle
this is your starting position press the
right dumbbell
up toward the ceiling by flexing and
engaging your chest muscle
lower it back down and alternate with
the left dumbbell
so keep alternating between hands you
should feel the engagement on your chest
muscles to engage your chest the
dumbbells should always maintain a chest
level so don't lift it too high by
alternating the presses
this will increase and maintain the
tension on the lowered
arm once you have completed 12
repetitions on each side
drop the dumbbells and get down onto the
floor
for narrow push-ups for narrow push-ups
you want to keep your arms close to your
body with your elbows pointed back
lower yourself down and push up using
the strength
from your triceps this is a more
challenging workout
so let's keep it to 10 to 12 repetitions
if you're struggling to do the full
push-up then drop onto your knees
remember to engage your core and keep
your back flat
do not arch your lower back your upper
body should be feeling
really tired by now take a short break
and complete another
two to three more sets and let's move
into the final super set
it's going to be a total body movement
focusing
on your core kettlebell swing and plank
if you have a kettlebell then grab one
that weighs between 8 to 16 kilos
if not you can also replace this with a
dumbbell
stand slightly wider than shoulder width
apart with the kettlebell
in the middle hold the kettlebell with
both arms
you want to keep a slight bend at the
knees
slowly lower the kettlebells back
between your legs to create momentum
use the power from your hips and core
drive your hips forward and straighten
your back to bring the kettlebell
up to shoulder level let the kettlebell
return
between your legs and repeat the
movement remember that
the power should be coming from your
hips and your core
not your upper body so your arms should
only be helping you to hold on to the
kettlebell
this is a great explosive movement to
not only work on your core
but to work on your total body in
increasing your heart rate and burn
fat i love to do this workout as my
finisher exercise
once you've completed all your wraps get
down
onto the floor into a plank brace your
core
keep your back flat and maintain this
plank position
do not arch your lower back or pipe your
butt up hold the plank
for 40 seconds and in the final 20
seconds
let's rock forward and back
so that's going to challenge your core
even more
only 20 seconds
[Music]
and you're done take a short break
stretch if you need to
and complete another two to three more
sets
before you end your workout you got this
supersets are a great technique for
those of you who are tight on time
this workout will hit all the major
muscles in
under one hour so try this workout
and you can even do it at home if you
have dumbbells and barbells
if you enjoy this workout if you want
more gym workouts then let me know in
the comments below
hit the like button share this video on
save this video and do subscribe to my
youtube channel check out a lot more
home workout videos gym workouts recipes
and nutritional tips
on my youtube channel and i will see you
next time stay safe
all the best